caroline est ce que vous avez déjà eu un
coup de foudre dans la rue vous croisez
un type comme ça vous vous dites lui il
faut vraiment que je que je le prenais
ce que je leur en mais qu'est ce qu'elle
fait qu'est-ce que vous répondez oui et
vous l'avez vous l'avait interpellé vous
avez parlé avec toujours pas toujours et
ben moi j'ai une application de
rencontres qui vous propose justement de
retrouver ce beau cette belle inconnue
que vous auriez croiser un peu plus tôt
dans la journée regarder on vous
explique tout retrouvez un bel inconnu
croisé dans la journée c'est possible
aujourd'hui j'ai envoyé ma localisation
tout au long de mes déplacements
donc je vais décide d'aller voir les
gens que j'ai croisés rue saint-honoré y
en a quatre je pouvoir les parcourir
6la like et ben c'est parfait c'est un
crush elle m'avait laïque et avant pour
avoir le coup de foudre à coup sûr des
algorithmes vont encore plus loin ils
trient les profils compatibles pour
créer les meilleures combinaisons
partout dans le monde
dans la vie tout est toujours une
histoire de chance ou d'opportunités
voilà on est dans le métro on voit
quelqu'un on a envie de lui parler puis
au moment où se décident les portes
s'ouvrent et la personne des sens et
grâce à apple on va pouvoir retrouver
cette personne est allé vers elle alors
qu'est ce qu'on en pense de cette chance
qu'on provoque avec une application
supplémentaire
est-ce que déjà peut-être on peut
revenir sur le magnéto et sur le visage
ah oui et surtout ils sont magnifiques
trop court on a assez dans lequel aurait
certes m et faux pont mirabeau
absolument là toutes les deux vallées
rappeler un caroline ithurbide qu'elle
est quasiment marier avec d'ailleurs moi
j'ai eu un coup de foudre j'ai eu un
coup de foudre pour votre père de
maisons avant bah oui mais ce qui était
pratique c'était que c'était au bureau
donc chez arrive et bim
ah oui je trouve magnifique on leur a
croisé c'est facile mais j'adore
l'application génial mais c'est une très
très bonne idée non on aura ne sera
jamais trop et b pour aller vers l'amour
quoi nous ils n'ont pas ce que ça gâche
tout moi je crois au destin
mais là le dollar
la première - honda ça ne provoque pas
sinon ce n'est pas le destin si vous
croisez quelqu'un qui vous plaît et que
vous ne recroise croisé pas c'était
juste un petit voilà un petit truc par
contre si vraiment cette personne peut
être passé à côté de l'amour de votre
vie mais non si on doit se retrouver on
se retrouvera moi avec ma compagne on a
eu plein de rendez vous manqués comme ça
pendant des années alors qu'elle était
en couple le jour elle s'est retrouvée
célibataire vivant on s'est rencontré et
ça fait sept ans qu'on est ensemble et
des salles destin pas pour vous c'est ça
d'accueil et vous voulez pas qu'on donne
un petit coup de pouce
non sinon c'est plus le dessin c'est
juste un truc programmé sur internet et
je trouve ça dommage mais peu importe le
résultat c'est qu'après vous êtes
amoureux
je suis une grande romantique
contrairement à ce que dit de demeurer à
ma droite et là je ne tolère pas ce type
de roche et d' insulte et en plus j'ai
de gros doutes sur sa sueur sur ce
qu'elle raconte parce que à mon avis la
plus tôt rencontré dans un bar et ça a
été compris les shebab qui nient pas
d'entendre les sites de rencontres ça
concerne 30 % des 18-25 ans donc ça
cartonne et une raison c'est parfois on
n'a pas le temps en effet et quand le
monsieur dit où est ce qu'on n'a pas
toujours le temps pour l'amour alors là
la wii est ce qu'on peut répondre à ça
forcément mais non mais quand on prend
c'est le cas dans le métro ou même en
allant au travail on n'a pas le temps
forcément est par contre c'est pas il
nous a dit quand même on n'a pas le
temps de s'arrêter pour discuter non
l'homme ne veut pas forcément que dix
très bien
quelqu'un aux téléspectateurs une
application pour trouver quelqu'un qu'on
a croisé dans la rue c'est utile ou pas
utile à 48 % utilisent pas utile à 52%
pour l'instant ça fait son petit
bonhomme de chemin
c'est un peu comme ici à deux pour nous
contre